now I have the great pleasure of being
joined by someone that I'm a big fan of
both for his radio show and for his
writing Eric Metaxas host of the Eric
Metaxas show and author of the new book
Martin Luther the man who rediscovered
God and changed the world
now Eric I do not share your admiration
of the corpulent German exactly but I
did really enjoy the book
I thought the narrative is very
compelling very readable and I learned
so much about Martin Luther that I
didn't know before and more importantly
I unlearned so many things about Martin
Luther that I did know it's like what
Ronald Reagan used to say it's not that
our liberal friends are ignorant they
just know so much that isn't so that
basically was my view of Luther and your
book corrected that a lot so yeah what
what made you write it most of what we
know about him is a myth or a legend or
at least a half truth for just to say a
lie um I didn't go into this book I
don't go into any of my books to knowing
what I want to write I just go in with a
healthy level of ignorance and curiosity
and honesty and I say I'm just gonna
write what I find but what I found about
Luther was that much of what is said
about him over and over and over is just
not true the first thing is everybody
says he was raised in a very poor family
that his father was a poor miner he
often said cata like politicians sort of
furnish their street cred you know
they're humble bona fides
he says that my father was a humble
miner that's true and it's not true his
father was a successful businessman in
the mining business
he was socially upwardly mobile which is
an extraordinary thing in the 1480s that
there was enough of a free market that
somebody could be not wealthy but could
get wealthy or could work hard and that
there was enough of a opportunity let's
say so the father borrowed it seems a
lot of money from the mother's family
and started this huge business and I had
to work very hard to justify the loan to
get it you know to work out so these
were hard workers but the more we know
about Luther there's a bunch of things
in the book that are brand-new I talked
about a a couple of archaeological
things that was done 2003 2008 where
they discovered that the axe
house that Luther Corning is three times
as large as they've been saying for 500
so it's kind of crazy and then they
found a lot of garbage trash and they
could think through it and they they
discovered real evidence that these were
people of some means he was not raised
in under difficult circumstances you
read the book thank you I really enjoyed
the book I read it over a cigar because
the body is a temple and the temple
needs incense the the claim that comes
later on in the book that you point out
which is probably the essence of the
Protestant revolution and it's what
Hamlet talks about is that Luther
cracked the cover of objective truth
cracked the authority and the the
ownership of objective truths and we've
seen a lot of varied consequences from
that on the one hand we have political
freedom and the nation-states and
liberal democracy on the other hand you
and I both attended a former university
called Yale and there are people run
wreaking havoc over there because have
they changed the name because he was a
slave holder he was a slave trader they
have to change it to I don't know mr.
Rogers University yeah I think man ever
to graduate from Yale at least previous
centuries and I think that they should
change the name but yes the world the
door that Luther opened we all know led
to tremendous things and to terrible
things that's part of the price of
freedom right in other words when you
say to people you are free you are free
to say and believe stupid things or the
to saying believes wonderful things
that's freedom in America we protect
people who say things we disagree with
that's at the essence of freedom you
know and I know that it feel more
complicated than that I wrote a whole
book called if you can keep it my book
before this where I go into how if you
don't have a virtuous populace if faith
is not at the heart of the culture
self-government doesn't work people will
destroy themselves as has happened many
times in the past
market will not give us everything we're
looking for these things need to have
people running them in such a way that
they're going to give us what we want
right so what Luther enabled I think but
the great things but it also led to many
terrible things I'll be the first to say
it and I'd love the point about mass
communication I loved when you're
writing about how Luther himself didn't
intend for his 95 theses to spread as
quickly as they did is ubiquitously as
they did almost like a facebook debate
you know it gets out of hand and
everybody sees it and he said he had
some doubts about them he might have
written it differently how instrumental
were two things to the spread of those
theses the sale of indulgences my only
quibble with your book by the way is I
felt you were a little harsh on Pope
Sixtus the fourth I felt that he but you
know everything people are a little
harsh on Sixtus and and they the
confusion over the sale of indulgences
married to this printing press where
people on the other side of the world
end up reading Luther's thesis and say
Oh Martin good job pal I didn't I didn't
know you read it the channels of
communication effectively don't exist
the cultural elites which in those days
were a church and the state have
complete control and if you try to get a
message to somebody else you can't
there's just no ability to do that
suddenly somebody invents the printing
press and you can write something and
whether you like it or not someone else
to copy it and print it and distribute
it very cheaply and then people who get
it can reprint it and distribute it and
it goes on and on it's no different than
you know forwarding something hitting
reply all and it goes to everybody and
you think uh-oh what just happened that
wasn't possible 10 years ago or 20 years
ago but suddenly everybody knows and
there's no way to get the horse back in
the barn Luther's theses I mean one of
the hugest misconceptions in the story
of Luther which you know it's such a
good story people want to believe it but
they have this idea that in 1517 this
young man wanted to stick his finger in
the Pope's eye and post this in sin
a document in the most incendiary place
imaginable hey how about the church door
and then you find out no no no no no
that we're looking at it you know from a
different perspective what happened at
the time was a humble monk who loved his
church and loved his poll wanted to
bring attention to something that he
thought was dragging the church's name
through the mud and he did this for the
church for the honor of the church he
said this is not right
that we have allowed the practice of
indulgences to get out of hand so that
people come into my confessional and
thrown this piece of paper in front of
me saying hey Padre Oh what can I get
for this
you know a lot of penance free card
right that's what it is so Luther saw as
a brilliant theologian and as a very
serious priest and monk he said this is
bad for the faithful the souls of my
flock are in danger and so he says we
need to have an academic debate a proper
academic debate but everybody was having
academic it's what you did when there
was you know trouble you said let's
discuss it so he writes in lat he ninety
five points
some of them slightly provocative
because you wanted to provoke a good
academic debate and he posts it on the
local bulletin board which is the church
door but it but it says if so you
picture him with a hammer and nails
thundering against the papacy you know
that's completely wrong data Rama
theology right might as well picture him
with a pushpin down by the laundry room
putting it on the bulletin board next to
the thing with the missing cat and the
guitar lessons I mean basically that's
what he did was quiet and somehow it
just spread and spread and it got way
out of hand he never intended it it
caused trouble that's the fact
and speaking of his deference to the
Pope and not trying to do you know poke
a nail into his eye there's the the most
heartbreaking moment of the story is
that he writes the letter to the Pope he
writes a letter to Leo the tenth I
believe and it never is sent let's see
this is the thing you start I mean I
hope people will read the book because
it's startling and stunning when you see
what actually happened it's not it's the
way real life works and dumb little
thing happens stupid people
misunderstand
thinks good people misunderstand things
Milt it's who is this papal Leggett sent
to kind of deal with Luther made some
terrible mistakes and a couple of other
people involved
terrible mistakes he kind of kept
thinking if I could deal directly with
the Pope surely he has to see what I'm
saying is correct I'm not trying to up
end Catholic doctrine his point is that
the the Pope the Christian doctrine
church doctrine on indulgences is that
you know that remits penance and
temporal punishment for sin and while
the Pope doesn't have jurisdiction over
souls in purgatory he can intercede on
your behalf you can ask really nicely
for those souls to have less punishment
and then you'll get guys like Tetzel
down at the ground who are Hawking when
the coin rings than a soul out of
purgatory Springs so so much seems to be
Luther wanting to reach the Pope wanting
to go directly to the the Vicar of
Christ on earth the Barca Peter I mean
look it's so different than a prop than
a president like Reagan not knowing
what's happening with his guys with
iran-contra right I mean you realize
that it's very complicated so he's on
the hook ultimately but there are people
that he has trusted and obviously people
like Tetzel were very fast and loose and
the corruption one moment that struck me
is when Luther had not talked to his
father for a while because his father
wanted to become a lawyer
so he's this genius he's clearly a
prodigy just as he's about to become a
lawyer he doesn't want to become a
lawyer he's struck down there's this guy
oh man this vision this Thunderbolt and
right
eventually they reconcile and Luther's
father says God grant that that was not
an apparition of the devil that for that
convinced you you know to go and enter
into the monastery what are the odds
that it was an apparition of the devil
five hundred years later the fact is it
could have been but it doesn't matter
because we serve a God who was able to
braid plans B C and D back in to plan a
Luther his heart was in the right place
and you know the Bible says God looks on
the heart
this was a man who wanted what God
wanted and so sometimes we struggle to
figure out what is it that God what is
God like when he did this initially his
whole view of God was wrong
he had a view of God as a nasty judge
who was just slathering ruling to throw
people into hell if you have that view
of God you're gonna act accordingly
Luther thought the only thing I can do
to cover my rear end is to go into the
monastery I'm not gonna risk eternal
hell for a good luck career so he goes
to the monastery really you know to
cover his rear end and when he gets
there he tries as hard as anyone to pray
his way into the peace of God and to in
effect earn his way he could this is
what happens is that he has this sense
that I've got to do this and this and
this this I've got to jump through these
hoops and you feel like you're
performing and you're failing and what
kind of God would put you through that
hell so you begin to resent God and hate
God he's reading the Bible reading the
Bible of course famously at some point
he discovers this idea that we are saved
by faith the righteousness of God is
given to us
it's not something that God uses to beat
us into hell he gives it to us as a free
gift so it turns his world upside down
and right around the same time was when
he decided to post the theses on
indulgences and so it all kind of
exploded there at you the portrait you
paint as you've just described is of a
guy who is an obsessive he's a neurotic
he is constantly worrying himself to
death he seems to have a great fear of
death he's so gaunt and thin not like
that portrait that we imagined of him
and then later on he becomes this Gary
Ellis fat German fellow and he's
constantly troubled by intestinal pains
a priest friend of mine because of the
word in cloaca or ox cloaca the that
it's his suggestion that he had his
epiphany about Romans while sitting on
the commode and my priest right and
wondered what torrent of commentary he
could have unleashed on the world with
the modern colonic irrigation that is
neither here nor there
I make fun of the Freudian offense you
know that's that's what I want are these
Freudian Theory right in that I mean
there was a guy named Eric Erickson who
wrote a book about Luthor called young
man Luthor and if you want to talk about
a mid-century horror of a cliche forty
in the three hundred and fifty pages of
Freudian nonsense really giving Luthor
no real credit for being a person he's a
rational in it acts of urges and
constipation and libido and hey that's
what makes the world go round but in
1958 it was difficult to argue against
it so so yeah people really
misunderstand Luthor in that way too
they said his father was really cruel
and he was rebelling against his father
and there was this oedipal spasm against
his father and the father god that made
him do everything he did it's completely
ridiculous and again the least you can
do in a biography and I hope I do in my
book is simply tell the facts and a
story emerges from the facts at least if
you have enough facts and at this point
we can say we do you certainly achieve
it in the book it's really really good I
highly recommend it even as a very Pope
ish fellow and traditionalist
conservative I really really enjoyed it
I recommend that everybody go out and
read it it's Martin Luther the man who
rediscovered God and changed the world
we can quibble about maybe the subtitle
or six just the fourth or what-have-you
but a really good black everyone should
go ahead and read it and of course
listen to the Eric Metaxas show it's a
great show and Eric thanks for being
here and we definitely want to have you
back as soon as possible
Michael oh is my joy thank you so much